if you were trapped on the island of
death what would you do you're gonna be
forced to find the elixir of life and
will have to fight other prisoners and
creatures with god-like powers and
flesh-eating monsters in order to reach
it I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the immortal tencent in Hell's Paradise
this guy is going to be forced to face
the most horrifying Island gods in
existence Gaby Maru has just been
sentenced to death by his own Town's
warlord he's a professional Shinobi
ninja who has been trained so well that
is almost impossible to kill this
executioner gets ready to chop his head
off and brings his blade down hard but
then it breaks and everybody is shocked
including cabimaru he wants to die but
each time the village fails to kill him
and he goes back to his cage after
another failed day of death there he
starts to talk to this long-haired woman
who had been sent to take his statement
and she also finds out that he was
trying to leave the village and take his
wife with him but he was captured by the
wife's Village Chief and this lady
thinks for some reason Gabi Maru is
lying the next few days the Village
throws everything they have at him to
try and kill him burning him alive at
the stake nope buried alive nope having
his legs and privates get pulled apart
by bulls and have him get ripped in half
from the bottom up nope nothing works
however this long-haired lady who was
also at the executions notices Gabby
Marv's legs slightly resisting getting
pulled apart later that night she goes
to him and tells him that he claims he
wants to die but it almost seems like to
her that he actually wants to live why
does he not let himself die and even
Gabby Maro has no idea what she's
talking about she then asks him again
why he tried to leave the village but
just then this Noble tells her to stop
asking pointless questions and then she
finds out from one of the guards who
Gabi Maru really is he's known as Gabi
Maru the hollow a monster that has
killed many many men and his ninja Clan
is rumored to have all taken an Elixir
that has given them immortality because
that must be the reason why he can't die
nothing they do can kill him they also
state that this Elixir can be found in a
mysterious place called shinseng you
later Gabby Maro is sent to the strange
room and he sees the long-haired woman
from earlier out of options The Village
has finally hired her to kill Gabby Maru
once and for all he thinks they will
fail once again but the warlord then
Smiles he's sent for this woman named
sagiri and she's not just a statement
taker but she is actually a ronin
executioner and belongs to the best
executioner clan in Japan the Yamada
Clan she tells him that since he wants
to die she'll Grant him his wish just
then Gabby Morrow senses her power in a
split second and subconsciously Dodges
her incoming attack breaking out of his
handcuffs tagiri asks him why he's
trying to escape and that's when he
realizes that since his survival
Instinct is so strong he must not
actually want to die she then tells him
that she knows he lied about his wife
and that he was actually planning to
escape this Village and the ninja life
with his wife but he got captured by her
father shocked that she figured this out
Gabby Maro is about to attack her when
she pulls out a letter a letter that is
going to solve all of his problems she
tells him that this contains a king's
pardon and will allow anyone who owns
this letter to be free but in order to
get this there's one condition he must
go with her to a Mysterious World known
as Shin sen Kyo the land of no suffering
in order to find the elixir of
immortality this is the real reason why
she is here okay we've just been granted
the opportunity of a lifetime this is
great but if I was Gabby Morrow I'd
actually steal my freedom with sagiri's
hunko Let Me Explain I would only agree
to go if zigiri first sent an official
letter stating to the Shogun that I had
agreed that I'm gonna go to the island
because that's going to buy me some time
for what comes next once she confirms
that the letter was sent to the Shogun I
would then quickly kill her and then
take the letter of the pardon as well as
any money or anything else that she's
got on her and this is very important
because after that I'm gonna go find my
plane Jane Y and then we're gonna spend
the next few weeks trying to get out of
here I'm also going to send a second
letter posing as sigiri that not only
did I find the Elixir but I found way
more than I could carry and I'm gonna
need some extra time delivering it all
the way back home but in order to make
the letter more convincing and more
official I'm gonna get extra creative on
this part now it's noted that the story
takes place between 1603 to 1867 and the
modernization of Japan didn't really
occur until 1870. and this means that
during this time period only the rich
and certain people of higher ranking had
access to hanko which basically means
letter SEALS or like a royal stamp only
people in privileged positions were able
to seal their letters using their own
their families or their Clan's very own
personalized seal in order to prove that
the letter was sent by them basically
kind of like a Twitter verified check
mark or Instagram but that doesn't count
anymore because now you can buy one and
because of this it's very likely that
sigiri could very well be carrying her
very own hanko seal belonging to her or
her royal Clan intent isn't that
interesting and with all of these
professional letters this is going to
buy us a lot more time while I work on
getting my wife back getting both of us
out of this country and living a nice
life somewhere on the beach somewhere
and this myth paradise city is located
in the southwestern sea further than
ryuku kingdom and the island has
recently just been discovered and this
is where apparently the elixir of
immortality is located but there's one
big problem none of the explorers that
they've sent to look for it have ever
returned except for one a half-dead
corpse filled with beautiful flowers she
has been sent by a king to recruit evil
Warriors capable of handling this threat
and if they retrieve the Elixir and make
it back alive They will receive their
freedom this is the only way Gabi Maro
will ever be able to return to his wife
and so he accepts her offer the two then
leave the village of this angry warlord
by using Gabby maru's ninja Fire monk
art and then they set off to go and find
the elixir of immortality the next day
they get picked up by the King's Men and
Gabby Maru is taken to a meeting with
the King along with all the other most
terrifying criminals of Japan The Fad
King announces that they are all here
for the same reason to find and bring
back the elixir of immortality from this
Mysterious Island in exchange for their
freedom but then he reveals only the
person who hands him the Elixir will be
given their freedom meaning all the
criminals here will be forced to kill
each other sooner or later if the island
doesn't kill them first they get their
blindfolds taken off and one of the
soldiers reveals the only person who has
returned from the island this flowered
corpse returning from the trip this man
immediately started to become sick and
soon lost his mind to this mysterious
disease this is what awaits them on
their trip and then this one six-pack
stud of an idiot doesn't think that the
deal is worth it and gets up to leave
but that's when his head gets chopped
off by one of the executioners and the
prisoners quickly figure out what's
really going on here since everybody
here has been sentenced to death what
has changed nothing if they don't go on
this Mission they'll all be killed right
here right now and they're not being
sent alone oh no no no each prisoner is
going to be escorted by a professional
executor from the Yamada Clan each one
of these Master Swordsmen surrounding
the prisoners will be assigned to them
they take out their swords and point it
to the person they will be looking over
sagiri points to Gabby Maru if the
prisoners try anything they will die if
they try to kill their escort and leave
the island they will die if they return
from the island without the Elixir they
will not be allowed to board the return
boat in short other than returning with
the Elixir they will die the king then
says no time like the present and that
their transport doesn't have enough
seats so I guess the need to make the
group smaller and they're all criminals
and they all quickly begin to figure out
exactly what he means and everybody
begins to brutally murder each other
using whatever they have on hand and
turning each other into nasty Shields of
meat meanwhile the King asks which one
of these prisoners have extraordinary
abilities and his assistant points to
the select few meanwhile sigiri's boss
Whispers to her that he doesn't think
she has what it takes to kill the
prisoners if they need to and says while
she's a good fighter she's not a good
warrior because she is a woman he thinks
that as the Royal daughter of this clan
she should go back to her Palace but she
tells him nah a group of prisoners
suddenly noticed Gabby Maru not fighting
and challenge him knowing they won't
stop until they kill him Gabby Morrow
tells them that he must get back home to
his wife and that he's sorry for for
what's about to happen next unleashing
Hellstorm he brutally Slaughters
everyone here skinning their flesh
biting their necks real tasty stuff and
proves to everyone that he's as powerful
as his Legend suggests the bloodbath
then ends as these remaining survivors
are declared the official Hunting Party
The King then wishes them luck and tells
them that they're heading to the land of
paradise and that they shouldn't be
afraid but of course nobody believed
that why days later they finally reached
the mythical island sargeria is shocked
that this place is real and thinks then
of course the Elixir must exist too
entering this jungle looking Paradise
Gabby Mario quickly gets out of his
handcuffs but she notices and tells him
to put them back on and he's like what
the frick man and he tells her you know
I can't fight as well with my hands tied
come on come here break but she says
Nope and she makes him put his handcuffs
back on we cannot go one more step any
deeper into this island because of this
look at this right here look at this
Mangrove tree frame we can't go on to
this island I will explain this chick is
either really stupid or worst a really
talented liability at best and this is
why I'm going to focus on getting away
from her either by Breaking Free or
separating or by murdering the [__] out
of her in case she tries to come after
us because she is a goody two shoes and
it's really annoying and now that the
liability is gone we need to think
strategically because based on what
we've seen there's no point in finding
the Elixir for two reasons one we've
seen what this Forest is capable of
earlier and even though we don't know
how it does it it means we don't need to
investigate and find out because well I
want to live two this Forest is located
based on what we know past the ryuku
kingdom and if we compare this to on the
map right here it means very likely that
this island is located within a
subtropical zone of East China Sea which
I'm going to refer back to these
mangrove trees right here because it
further confirms my theory as
subtropical zones likely means low
pressure environments and sudden changes
in temperatures and this basically means
that this area is known for crazy
dangerous high winds and being in a
subtropical Zone means that we're likely
going to encounter storms around the
island the further we get away from the
island it's like you're trying to leave
an island and then up too late you're in
the center of storm sucks to be you this
is why strategically I would probably
kill sagiri and wait for the others to
find the Elixir and once they try to get
back to the boats to head home then it
would kill them off allowing us to steal
the Elixir and take a sip just in case
we have a rough time on the Seas that we
were not gonna die because we're
Immortal Gabby Marvel then gets you
ready to reply back to that stupid
statement then his face gets smashed in
by this prisoner Hunter of a hundred
zagiri thinks he's dead but he quickly
gets back up and he tells everybody that
he just broke his neck but he'll be fine
shocking everybody here except Gabby
Maru he then notices this prisoner not
wearing handcuffs either and whines
about it too sugiri curious herself she
looks to this prisoner's escort but he
says that nobody here gives a [__] about
any of the rules on this island and
makes fun of her for always being a
goody two-shoes he says there aren't any
rules on this island if his prisoner
dies he can just go back home and he
warns sagiri that all these prisoners
cannot be trusted because while they all
try to kill each other they could very
easily turn on them and try to kill them
as well and all of it could happen
before they even reach the Elixir man
meanwhile his prisoner challenges Gabby
Morrow to a death match and says he's
got time to reduce his competition
annoyed about this side challenge he
quickly Slaughters this guy in seconds
and announces that they've wasted too
much time already and then sagiri's
co-worker tells her to watch her back
because in a few hours things are going
to change and he walks over and cuts his
prisoner's head to clean off and gets
ready to leave the island and that's
when Gabby Morrow strikes and tries to
kill sagiri but she quickly blocks him
and he tells her that he was trying to
be merciful about it because she's only
going to get in his way and he quickly
overpowers her and holds a sword to her
neck and everything within him is
telling him to kill this woman telling
her that if his ninja Clan reaches this
island and finds Elixir before they do
it's all over and she has no idea what
he's talking about and Gabby Maro tries
to kill her but then he realizes he's
not the same anymore ever since he met
his wife doesn't have it in him and
realize that he never wanted to kill he
never wanted this to be his life's work
and then he starts to get emotional and
tells the Gary that he must kill her so
that he can get back home to his wife
but zagiri then realizes he's just like
her a human and then in just 5 anime
seconds they become all Pally that they
offer to work together to get out of
here and join forces but then they get
surrounded by horrifying creatures that
they've never seen before this fish
creature tries to attack forcing these
two to defend themselves and more hordes
of crazy monsters show up and exactly
eerily enough the same way as the Titans
do an attack on Titan knowing they're
not going to survive much longer Gabby
Maro activates his ninja Fire Master art
and Slaughters these monsters one by one
not paying attention though and just
like a typical anime girl Damsel in
Distress situation sagiri gets caught in
a trap she's so stupid forcing Gabby
Morrow to rush over to save her causing
him to become exposed and now he's going
to die but then he gets saved by some
other criminals and they introduce
themselves as usury of keshu and her two
escorts Genji and this glasses guy
knowing they have a better shot at
survival as a group Gabby Maru says that
they should work together and ignores
yuzario coming on to him again and again
and again it's really annoying and then
this glasses guy then says his prisoner
got killed by useria so he decided to
watch over her since she seems dangerous
but sagiri thinks that this guy is just
creeping out on her since he's wearing
glasses reluctantly everybody agrees to
play fair for now and exchange
information about what they've
discovered about this terrifying place
from what they've seen the bugs here
have human looking faces that are lethal
and their poison can cause
hallucinations followed by a very quick
and very painful death use area reveals
that she already knows about all of this
why oh well she did nothing she just uh
well kidnapped one of the prisoners and
then tried out all of the bugs that she
could find that use them on his tied up
body horrifying sagiri and she passes
out whoa this is crazy if we don't
escape this situation right now we might
end up dying by snooze new let me
explain we now have a ragtag group of
weirdos that we cannot trust usury is so
freaking good at her job that she
somehow made glasses guy and Genji her
toys and staying here doesn't make sense
as it likely means that what just
happened with those monsters is gonna
happen again fighting them like that
continuously is going to wear us down
where we should work on saving our
energy trying to find the Elixir if I
was them I would first map out a new
strategy consisting of us avoiding all
conflict from the next time we get
cornered by monsters it's noted that the
battle that we just faced a monsters
quickly surrounded us and we were likely
unevenly spaced out and this means
trying to escape between one of them
still could have gotten us picked off by
the others nearby which is why the next
time this happens I'm going to instruct
everybody to huddle in tightly together
and wait for the larger monsters to
encircle Us in at a much closer range
then from there all of us would be able
to Sprint through their giant legs and
use that opening as a means of escape
and also use the bigger monsters as
Shields preventing the other ones from
getting us because the bigger ones are
already in the way by avoiding fighting
as much as possible preserving our
energy in order to try and find the
Elixir should be our first priority and
also we should try to get to Higher
Ground and spot where the center of this
island is because the Elixir will
probably be located somewhere further in
the island also we gotta stay away from
useria because she crazy and she's
coming on to us all the freaking time
really annoying and she's gonna put my
head in a nasty headlock yeah no I don't
want to be there later so gittery wakes
up and finds out from Genji she was
exposed to a toxic butterfly she quickly
gets up to look for her prisoner but
finds Gabby Maro and the rest just
chilling outside they didn't go anywhere
and they think that they need to sort
out all of their information beforehand
before they continue to look for The
Elixir Gabby Morrow says that while she
was taking a nap he looked around and
couldn't find any Elixir that looked
like this picture that they got and how
the fragnas would you be able to know
what the Elixir looks like but Poker
Face Gabby Morrow tells her nothing he
doesn't tell her that his psychotic
Village Chief most likely had located it
years ago so he tells her that he was
just well winging it because that's what
ninjas do and glasses guy says the
picture that they have of The Elixir
likely isn't even accurate that maybe
they should start looking at the island
for Clues instead because for one who
made the statues that they saw all
around the island because finding this
out could lead them to the Elixir or at
least give them information about where
to look sigiri then chimes in and says
that even the bugs that she killed were
weird when she cut into them she
couldn't feel any organs inside them and
that they quickly realized that even the
big monsters that they fought looked
like half-baked Gods too unrealistic to
be natural and too artificial to be a
manifestation of a natural occurrence
and then Gabby Maru has a crazy idea and
says that a creature that lives without
any organs is a clue to immortality it
means that this Elixir might just be on
this island Genji then confronts zagiri
and tells her that she should go home to
the mainland because she's the daughter
of the royal Yamada Clan but she tells
him again nah and later that night Gabby
modern sigiri Bond over some cute
useless crap that I'm not going to talk
about why because they have no idea
they're all about to get slaughtered
because the very next day Genji tells
sagiri that she's leaving whether she
likes it or not but she defies him again
and he calls her a bad girl and is about
to punish her when she blocks him steals
his sword but just then one of the
prisoners appears from behind and tries
to grab her genshi quickly saves her by
pushing her out of the way but gets
brutally injured sigiri's horrified and
goes to Genji but he tells her to run
but just then Gabby Maru Super Kicks
this prisoner and sagiri says that
they're up against the giant of 10 and
Gabby Morrow notices this man's eyes are
looking at them not like a human like an
animal eyeing up their prey Gabby
Marlton analyzes his opponent right as
this monster throws a freaking tree but
he Dodges gabymaro asks useria to help
him out and use her ninja skills but she
says no I like it up here and I love
this show you're doing great work keep
it up great forcing Gabby Morrow to
dodge all of his attacks and he notices
that this monster is not just big and
strong but terrifyingly quick if those
hands touch him he's a dead man he then
uses his ninja art thunderstones and
kicks some rocks right at him at a
blistering speed but nothing happens he
then uses a ninja art known as flexible
blade turning the fabric around his
waist into a sword but this freak
defends it as well sagiri then shows up
and tells Gabby Maro that Genji has just
died but at the last minute revealed how
he was wrong about her and apologizing
blah blah blah it's not important and
with it she just barely manages to cut
off his pinky finger well that's helpful
telling him that only by weaving through
the gaps of the skeletal structure will
you be able to cut someone in two that's
a fun bit of information to know and
they both quickly realized that the only
way they can take this monster down is
in one move Gabby Morrow tells her that
they need to bring him down to his knees
so she can cut his head off forcing her
to focus on her inner Powers all the
while as gamimaro distracts the giant
they try this idea but they aren't quick
enough Gabby Mario then activates every
single ninja trick in his book The Force
quickly starts to catch fire and he
starts coughing up blood he's running
out of time meanwhile useuria and
glasses guy stop being useless and
realize what these two are trying to do
by setting the forest on fire around
them smoke is going to be made and this
giant is going to breathe in a whole lot
of it which will eventually force him to
run out of breath Gabby Morrow then sees
that his plan is working and says that
with the heat around them it will cause
the smoke to rise first and because of
this they'll be safer down on the ground
okay what these guys are up against is
insane he's big he's strong and he's
freakishly fast when he shouldn't be let
me explain we're up against this guy a
huge Beast with 321 centimeters tall
born within the same string he killed
his entire Village as a child just by by
playing with them and then he started to
munch on them that's kind of nasty which
means he grew up alone from a very young
age most likely but it makes me wonder
how did anybody capture him in the first
place or think it was a good idea to
stand up on a mission when he can't even
speak or even understand what's going on
and on top of that this man clearly
suffers from gigantism the anime says oh
yeah he's still human and nothing else
applies but if that's the case it means
we should be able to apply the standard
rules of physics and human physiology to
this guy here's what I mean just like
the difference between a six foot man
and a 60-foot giant a giant in this
example may be 100 times as strong as
the man because he's freaking huge but
will also likely be one thousand times
as heavy as the man that means a giant
is going to be one tenth as fast as the
six-fun man he should not be able to
move this fast at all and even if he
could through some oh I don't know anime
magic square Cube loss states that as an
object size increases its volume
increases faster than its surface area
again man if he spanks him yourself he
struck his strength durability increases
but if he grows too large he would
become weaker and more vulnerable to
injury because as his size increases his
volume would increase much faster than
his strength because as a giant he would
not actually be that strong assuming
this great Cube law would apply in an
anime but literally break that theory
when he throws a freaking tree if the
square Cube law was not broken it would
mean that he's still human and not some
sort of mythical overpowered anime beast
and if I was Gabby mura I would
literally just chill out and crack open
a cold one and wait for this guy's giant
legs to literally break apart at any
time because with his huge frame
literally should not be able to support
his body quickly running out of breath
the giant finally drops to his knees
Gabby Morrow then rushes in and pins him
down using the last bit of his strength
and then sagiri finally slices through
his vertebrae bone cutting off his head
and winning this terrifying Death Match
unable to celebrate their Victory Gabby
Maro takes a Gary out of there before
the forest burns them alive running away
from the fires they soon reached their
teammates but there's something else
this abandoned The Village more so they
think the village of shin sen Kyo
glasses guy thinks that this Village is
where the sages live mysterious people
that use Sacred Hearts Gabby Morrow then
senses somebody watching them and then
catches them red-handed it's a child but
then a monster Rises up this wooden
creature basically a smaller version of
tree beard from Lord of the Rings Gabby
Morrow runs after the child and tells
his group to take care of this monster
they try to catch the girl but she
violently punches him in the stomach
causing him to bleed shocked they
realize she's not human pissed off Gaby
Maro finally gets a hold of her and says
they just want to find the Elixir and he
needs to tell her now but then she
starts crying confusing him it's really
annoying useuria and glasses guy catch
up and say that they've taken down the
monster but then it speaks and begs them
to give him back the mysterious child
desperate the wooden monster tells him
that he'll show them around his village
and tell them everything they want to
know about the Elixir but not of his
relationship with the girl cautiously
accepting his offer they give back the
little girl and are led to the ghost
Village the two introduce themselves as
Hokie and May and mentioned that this
place has been their home for over 1000
years and Hokie offers them a place to
recharge and reveals this island for
what it really is called shinseng Kyo
this island is also known as Kotaku home
of the terrifying Gods he confirms that
there is an elixir on this island and it
is referred to as tan drawing a map on
this island he says it's made up of
three regions one region holds the
forest and the beach is called Ashu the
second Inner Circle is called Hojo with
Elixir AKA tan being located in the
center most part of the island in an
area beyond the lethal fog in the horahi
region and the group is so freaking
happy they finally made it they have a
lead and Gabby Maro asks hokey if he's
seen the tan with his own eyes but the
tree tells him that oh you'll find the
tan soon enough when you find them and
says once they meet a man named Lord
tensin they will know how real The
Elixir really is upon hearing about Lord
tensin the group pays attention even
more and hoki tells them that this Lord
is part of a group of gods that run this
island Immortal beings powerful and
forever perfect he warns this group that
all of these monsters that they fought
into till now we're known toshin but
tensen is on a whole other level hokey
then tells them something he says the
only reason I invited you to this
Village it's not out of kindness oh no
it's out of pity because I know that
soon all of you will die a gruesome
death at the hands of these Island gods
and the group gets nervous of what he
says and Hokie warns them about what's
really going on every single group of
humans that has ever reached the island
has never left Lord tencent controls the
social these monsters and is known for
punishing Sinners and Intruders turning
those enemies into beautiful flowers and
in doing so releases them from sin and
uncleanliness and he helps them attain
Eternal Bliss at least that's what hokey
believes and the life force that becomes
a flower is the source of tan and all
the beings on the island benefit from it
benefit from the death of humans sagiri
asks why his kind has never tried to
leave but hoki tells her that all
they've ever wanted was to live on this
island alone and in peace and then he
cuts the conversation short real quick
and tells them to rest up for now going
off debate Gabby Maro mentions to sagiri
that they still only have bits of pieces
of information and he still doesn't
trust hoki at all that night the group
then decides to rest here and come up
with a plan on how to find the elixir of
immortality but Gabby Maru cannot wait
any longer and he ends up sneaking off
like the little [__] that he is to find
the Elixir without them waiting for what
seems to be ours he crosses this fog and
finally reaches the gates of harai home
to The Elixir and the terrifying gods
that live within but just then something
pops up behind him scaring him surprised
that something was able to sneak up on
him he sees this strange person and the
stranger asks Gabby Maru nicely if he
can run away quick because he's too lazy
to try and catch him but Gabby Maru
doesn't listen and tries to attack him
and that was his biggest mistake he
quickly realizes that he's outmatched
and is shocked at the monster in front
of him regenerating every injury every
wound every cut with insane abilities
and god-like speed it's just as fast as
he is Gabby Maro quickly realizes that
this must be one of the Masters of the
island one of the immortal gods standing
in front of him this creature comments
that gabimaru's body will make excellent
tan but Gabby Maro realizes that this
God's powers are very much so like mace
the two continue to go at it outside of
the gates unable to injure the god Gabby
Maro quickly deploys ninja art fire monk
skills against it and swiftly lands a
few hits finally overpowering Lord
Tenzin and he demands to know where the
Elixir is but the god
laughs at him and transforms into
something truly terrifying a giant
flower monster the chocolate from the
sudden transformation sends gebimaro
flying back and critically injuring him
out of energy and out of moves he uses
one more Ninja move a move that was
beaten into him by the village Chieftain
the warlord his master from his village
that forces an unconscious ninja to use
the remaining amount of his life force
and channel it outward and set his whole
body Up in Flames burning Lord tends him
alive and taking it down with capimaro
about to die May shows up out of nowhere
she followed him she grabs him and
magically creates a force field around
him and saves this Ninja's life and she
gets them the hell out of there Lord
tenzen watches them leave in shock
wonders what the hell is May doing
meanwhile the Sun finally Rises as
sigirian crew try to figure out where
gabimaru went but hoki says he'll join
them and take them to hurai since May is
also missing and he thinks she stupidly
followed Gabby Morrow so he's going to
join them to look for her on the way
siguri's group also finds out who Lord
tencent is known as the seventh Saiyan
he is one of seven Immortals according
to the legend hoki says a Satan once
climbed a mountain and became a God he
then split into seven and each one of
the seven have the same appearance and
voice and only their personalities and
roles differ and these seven rule the
island Hokie says this is all he knows
and the people in his village who lived
here before were once human in
appearance but lived longer life spans
but before they died they transformed
into tree-like structures rooting down
to the ground in hopes that their souls
would be led into the harai kingdom Ogie
reveals that most of them have very
little Consciousness left and shows them
his dead family the Lord tencent and his
seven personalities the ones who enters
harai elsewhere gabimaru finally wakes
up and realizes that may saved his life
he quickly realizes that he must kill
the Gods in order to get the elixir of
life but he cannot do it alone and just
then some familiar faces passes him by
this guy will call him goatee Samurai
and this Handler Fuji they accidentally
bumped into him and may they both
cautiously figure out their next moves
okay we just barely survived this
situation Against The Gods but I did
notice a few things that makes me think
that we can actually defeat them let me
explain first off Gabby Morrow you're
trying to fight Monsters by yourself
that's really stupid your wife's not
dead you have food there's literally no
reason to rush in without knowing more
about the situation and it almost cost
you your life if I was him I would count
my many blessings and take to finding
these two as a huge benefit to me
because up until now due to the chaotic
nature of how this team discovered more
information about this island made it
clear that no one single character knew
what was really going on this puts us
into a huge disadvantage even if you
didn't include how powerful these bad
guys were however there's one thing that
makes me think we do have a shot against
them it's noted that some of the attacks
that we've dealt towards these bastards
have shown to give stronger damage to
these Gods despite their insane strength
now while we don't know why certain
attacks damage them more than others the
fact is is that we could damage them and
this means despite their insane Powers
we can defeat them and are capable of
doing so at the very least which means
we could reverse engineer what we did in
any case however for now I would not
fight any more overpowered dudes at
least not till we meet back up with the
rest of our group and any other
prisoners that are still alive on this
island group thinking according to the
Journal of Personality and Social
Psychology has shown that group problem
solving works best when taggling
subjects within the fields of academics
business science and medicine as bigger
groups promote more big brain thinking
basically when you're in a group you
have more ideas him trying to figure
things out by himself is not going to
work as fast go tease Samurai and this
little kid Fuji tell him they've been
through hell to find the Elixir this guy
even lost his hand to a bug Fuji tells
everyone to chill though and says that
they should ask Gabby Maro about his
experiences so far and wear his escort
sagiri is and who the heck is this girl
behind him knowing he needs help Gabby
Maro agrees to chill out on offers for
them to work together spilling to be
into what he's been through and who Lord
tensin is and it's horrifying but goatee
Samurai Guy full of machismo decides to
help and reveals that he never wanted to
be pardoned for his crimes all he he
wanted was to become immortal through
Fame he only wanted to discover the
Elixir he doesn't actually want it for
himself and Justin May wakes up but she
looks different from before shocking
Gabby Maro now older she's now gone from
child to full-on waifu in 5 anime
seconds and they find out that she can
now talk better well that's helpful and
Gabby Mario quickly asks her about Lord
tensin and her powers and if she knows
how to defeat him and that's when she
reveals how to take him down she says
that he controls a form of energy known
as Dao but technically anybody can learn
it and if you master it you can achieve
Peak Dao and attain the powers and the
body of a God but the conversation is
cut short when they're discovered by
terrifying monsters a goatee Samurai guy
says that hey they can practice trying
to use Tao on them with the help of may
of course May watches the fight and
critiques their powers and tells them
they need to be weak but strong and weak
at the same time and it's really
confusing all the while is Fuji that
annoying little turd blossom researches
the Monsters finding out that they all
have different weaknesses and the
biology changes with each monster and it
makes no sense and they suspect that may
might be the same and that's when a
satanin appears and tries to kidnap may
it tells him that he's been looking for
her and then he needs to go back with
him to her eyes the same rank as Lord
tenzen the Saiyan tells humans that they
should be ashamed for hanging out with
her as they are merely her food and
Gabby Morrow totally gets confused and
realizes that he needs to figure out
what exactly May really is and why is
she helping him because things are
starting to get more suspicious so he
stands between them and her tells the
station that she isn't going anywhere
and this pisses the monster off and he
warns them that he'll turn them all into
tan and that's when more of his minions
appear they get ready to kill them all
Hussein then reveals that lady May is
important to him and his kind for their
doubt and he reveals what Dao really is
before they die he says there are five
trainings in order to increase someone's
down shoot 10 shoots
with the last and most important
training style called bochujutsu and
this one requires a training partner as
both parties circulate their ging and
yang by getting down and dirty and by
combining their nastiness it will
increase their overall doubt this Satan
says that Lord Tenzin is one horny hound
dog and has perfected both Jujutsu
training as he has both ying and yang
circulating within himself and this is
why he can transform into both genders
however people below him and regular
people only possess one type of Yang or
Yang these sentence as males have Ying
energy but they need May to perform both
Jujutsu because they need to get some of
her Sweeting energy but it's all for
training of course and shocks everybody
here from the same bloodline as Lord
tencent but weaker he states that she
was forced to become their training
partner in order to stay in harai
Kingdom but unable to take it any longer
she disappears and now they want her
back and this stuns Gabby borrow to his
core and is the last straw it then
unleashes his powers to a level that no
one has ever seen before not even him
full of doubt he creates this wall of
fire in front of these monsters blocking
them and giving his group time to plan
their next move Fuji quickly reveals
that he finally figured out what may was
trying to say earlier about using doubt
to control this power strength and
weakness must coexist in the mind and
may runs up to Gabby Morrow and
instructs him to weaken his mind slowing
everything down and that's when he
finally sees the true powers of Tao and
that's when everything changes he turns
around and gets ready to fight these
Island gods and says that uh he got the
gist and Fuji is stunned because he's
like that's not possible but he doesn't
listen Gabby Maro transforms into his
final form and kills monster after
Monster with more ease than ever before
watching him koti Samurai thinks that
his din to training likely made him
practice using something very similar to
Tao before without even realizing it
especially since some of the members of
his ninja Clan are rumored to have
Supernatural Powers after killing all of
the saien Gabby Maro forces this Doshi
to give up and reveals important
information about the island Gods saying
that there are three Doshi like him were
ordered to scout out this new batch of
humans that are arrived on the island
and this order was given by Lord tencent
and his group could sense that there was
something different about this latest
arrival of humans trying to fool Gabi
Maru Doshi tries to surprise kill him
but these two quickly Slaughter him for
good and Gabby Maru passes out waking up
a little later his group rests and he
goes into his own thoughts and quickly
begins to realize that his memories are
slowly starting to disappear and he's
finding it hard to remember why he's
here in the first place I made then asks
if he's alright he tells her he's fine
but she sees the outline of his soul
breaking apart right in front of her
meanwhile segeri's group continues to
try to look for Gabi Maru a glasses guy
thinks this place isn't the real Shin
sen Kyo and thinks this place has a fake
religion that was created by humans as
some of what they've seen other words
sitting in prayer have been used in
other religions just like those fish
monsters they fought earlier there seems
to be no real logic to anything that's
going on in the island and they think
they found their first real clue they
finally reached the gates of harai and
cautiously opened this door to the home
of the Gods but suddenly hokey's head
gets blown off by the strange man and he
collapses on the floor the group stares
in confusion but useria quickly realizes
what's going on and tries to run away
but then this stranger catches her with
superhuman speed still alive Hokie
reveals to the group what yusarea could
sense they've run into a tense Lord
tennzen then reveals that he heard what
glasses guy mentioned about the island
and tells him that his theory is correct
they made up a religion on the island to
help create order he then tells hoki
that once hoki dies his soul and his
family's Souls aren't going anywhere
this island is one big experiment and
everything on here is a test subject
shocking hokey in the group and that's
when these weird corpses Rise Up from
the dirt and grab on to use area these
zombies were all once humans who came to
the island and now this guy's experiment
not knowing what's true anymore glasses
guy nervously asks if the Elixir is real
and tension Smiles he states that only
good humans get made into tan and that
oh yeah The Elixir is real but the
Elixir only works on the gods any humans
who consumes it will simply turn into
hoki here and quickly die a painful
death use Aria could uses this time to
escape and swiftly Cuts Lord tenzen's
head clean off oh God he's dead they
tried to escape but that's when Lord
tensing quickly regenerates and tries to
recapture usuria curious he asks her if
she can use the powers of Dao herself
but she says in her training they call
it key Lord tends and smiles and tells
her that he'll teach her how to properly
use it with some bochujutsu but she says
Nah and quickly consumes a special ninja
potion shooting and combining different
types of ninja combinations and uses all
of her skills against Lord tenses
meanwhile desperate sigiri asks hoki if
the enemy has any weakness she needs to
know now and he tells her to cut him
down at the waist because that is where
his Tau resides hearing that she charges
at him and tries to cut him down but he
laughs and says that while sure yeah
that's his weakness she doesn't have any
power to cut him down but that's when
she channels more of her powers and
barely manages to give a small cut to
lortensive but this time everybody
realizes something is different he's not
healing shocking everybody here starting
to get the hang of it sigiri tells the
group that she can now sense an aura
around him the same one she felt around
campimaru and knows she now has access
to her Dow Powers directing the group
they work together to try to pin him
down purple hair girl distracts him
while glass's guy manages to sneak up
behind him to grab him unable to move
Now sigiri quickly channels her Samurai
skills and finally after a long battle
strikes Lord tensen down from his weak
point making him collapse instantly
finally he's dead and they think it's
over and they decide to take a quick
five that's when they noticed flowers
beginning to grow all around them and
one of these Vines shoots right at
useria glasses guy quickly jumps in
front of his wannabe Bay and gets
stabbed right in the chest falling down
to the floor and they watched this
flower disease begin to infect him the
whole ground around them begins to
rumble bursting out from the floor Lord
Tenzin Rises up but this time as a new
monster and he controls this Army Of
Vines shooting down right at the group
but that's when they're saved by the
baddest swordsman in the East a man
named shio and he shows up with this
Warrior as Narco eye one of the best
executioners in Japan he's blind and
concerns everything around him just like
Daredevil he proves his worth against
Lord tencent but gets cut by one of his
flowers and then sees horrifying flowers
begin to grow on his skin and Lord
tensin laughs and says that even just
one cut from him one scratch even will
result in him dying now he has no shot
of defeating him seeing this from the
distance the girl and sagiri think they
have to help him siguri says she's out
of energy so this girl hugs the [__] out
of her and somehow she gains her energy
back but she tries this on useria and it
doesn't work so Gary quickly suspects
that it's possible that Dao can be
shared between people you know
bochujutsu type stuff but less sexual
refreshed useria coats them in a ninja
potion to protect them against Lord
Tenzin and they rush over to help Shield
telling him the weakness in this monster
is his stomach his tandems both of them
the layout the game plan they'll take
the front and distract him while Shion
sneaks up from behind and Strikes both
tandems at once and they try out their
plan and zagiri Canal sense a doubt
energy all around her for the Running
Out of Time Lord tends and laughs as he
turns up his power level and these two
charged with the last bit of strength
sigiri then holds down one of Lord
tenson's arms and calls out to Shield he
charges his sword and gets ready to
strike but then he realizes he doesn't
feel any waves of Doubt coming from the
spot that they told him to and just then
glasses guy barely alive calls out to
him and reveals that as a flower his
tandem is in a different spot this one
right here where a flower collects its
nutrients and he charges up his powers
and Strikes down hard sending this Lord
to his deathbed once and for all after
showning glasses guy are about to die
but useria reveals that she only has
enough life-saving power potion for one
of them so they screw over glasses guy
and give it to shield and this wannabe
Loverboy creep kicks the bucket with one
more death on their hands sagiri vows to
not let anyone else die around her and
vows to get everyone off this island no
matter what it takes heading deeper into
the harai temple they rest up here and
Shion tells sigiri they now know that
Dao is a life force within anybody that
anyone can use it if they learn its
power however he suspects that using it
too much will begin to harm the body or
the spirit in various ways from
someone's memory to their Consciousness
sagiri then also mentions that Gabi Maru
said that the Elixir existed and he says
that his village Chief was Immortal
therefore must exist somewhere however
use area then chimes in and says that
what Gabi Maru saw could have been an
illusion a Magic Ninjas used to show
little kids and to fool subordinates
thinking the village Chief was Immortal
would have made them never try to oppose
his Rule and since Gabi Morrow grew up
among his ninja Clan there was a chance
that what he saw was not real useria
says that her ninja Clan does the exact
same thing to everyone including her and
thinks something else might be going on
with Gabby Maru sigiri's eyes widened as
she listens Gabby Morrow is still a
teenager meaning it's very unlikely that
as a ninja he would be married so young
in the first place and thinks that in
order to make Gabby Maro a better
Soldier somebody planted him with fake
memories of a wife in order to make him
more motivated to follow orders and from
that they're able to use him they're
able to motivate him to find the Elixir
and return back with it tagiri now in
shock tells useria to stop talking but
she keeps on poking holes in Gabby
Bonner's story asking if anyone has ever
seen his wife verified his claims or
even know the name of his wife that he's
mentioned a dozen times times before but
what do you guys think about the video
don't forget to like subscribe and leave
a thumbs up down below and as always
don't forget to check out our how to be
playlist